you can see I'm already set up my
synthetic division if you want to do it
long I have no problems with that you'll
know you got right if we get the same
answer again ok let's give this a go
first step simply division I just take
that leading coefficient and I just
write down that's all you need to do
okay and then I'm going to multiply and
multiply add you ready we can you'll
miss it ok multiply and I told you you
multiply and multiply add yeah happy
times ok now I've done the division but
remember I do you have to interpret what
does that mean ok here's my question
down here so again I'm still dividing a
cubic by a linear so I'm gonna get a
quadratic which is x squared takeaway
for X take away 2
what's that number on the end mate
there's a remainder of 0 ok hmm
now just I'm gonna let that linger for a
second I'm going to answer f I'm going
to answer F without any reference to
substitution I don't need to make a
substitution because the remainder
theorem tells me that P of negative 1 is
the remainder when that polynomial is
divided by X minus negative 1 X plus 1 I
just did that division right so I know
what the remainder is it's zero so I'm
just going to state it by the remainder
theorem of course there's no reason why
you can't just substitute it in when you
put in negative 1 here you're gonna get
negative 1 minus 3 plus 6 minus 2 you're
still gonna get zero okay at least if we
do something right
ok now what does this mean that this is
a special case when the remainder is
zero we no longer just called them
right let's rewrite our statement right
we're saying P of X is equal to this
times this Plus that Plus 0 right
so therefore what I've got is in fact
not just a divisor question remained up
I don't just have it devised a question
made up I have two factors there's no
thing hanging on the end there right
I've factorized P of X and this is a big
deal right this is a cubic we don't know
how to factorize qubits we've never
approached that kind of problem before
we've spent so long on quadratics and
looked at all these different ways of
dealing with quadratics the reason why
we have dodged cubic is because cubics
are hard core ticks are hard and
quintics are impossible I don't mean
that as like a rhetorical flourish I
actually mean that it's been proven it's
a bit crazy it's improving that you
cannot find analytically the way we've
been doing it like without a computer
that just crunches through the numbers
there's no method like this that
corresponds to if you've got an X to the
5 or 6 for any number higher so this is
a new kind of problem we've never
encountered before and we just nailed it
by kind of taking advantage of this guy
okay so this is a special case of the
remainder period when you get a
remainder of 0 you don't just get a
divisor quotient and remainder you get
factors okay so what I would say is and
on you can write this is your conclusion
we have factorized here X
because what we / the particular divisor
I gave you okay when we divided by X
plus one he's the key theme there was no
remainder when you divide like 50 by 10
the reason is there remain is just N is
a factor of 50 right so when we divide
explains by X plus 1
there was no remainder
so being that what we found is a case
where there isn't a remainder this
special case is no longer called the
remainder theorem
it's not about remained as anymore it's
about factors ok so again well to me one
day okay
a nice big box and this next result is
called the factor theorem it's really
kind of like the twin brother of the
remainder theorem that I just gave you
except for the fact that well it doesn't
have remained as it okay so underline
the fact that the intercept if you try
out this process you like just stick
numbers into your polynomial and then
some number that you choose gets you 0
disappears if P of a for some number a
is 0 right then X take away a that's why
I divided by Q sinh X take away a is a
factor of the polynomial you're after
okay so for instance if you had some
weed pollen but now I'm just making
stuff up so this is not actually it's
not actually going to be the case but if
I have some polynomial like this okay I
don't know three X to the 4 take away 2
x squared take away X plus 10 okay
and I look to this polynomial and I just
started plugging numbers into it right
and I was like ah what a P of 2 what
happens with that
if by coincidence right that ends up
being 0 then the factor theorem tells me
hey there's no remainder because this is
supposed to be a remainder if there's
the remainder then I have a factor okay
this would tell me that I should divide
by X minus 2 I can take this guy I can
do the division and then when I do
you'll still be no matter I'll have two
factors right that's really powerful
finding factors is really powerful
because then you know you know where the
roots are something is you draw it and
that's something we're gonna focus on
next week